après mai prochain
les observateurs anticipaient ce
résultat depuis quelques semaines les
militants l'ont confirmé de façon
écrasante le travail commence ce soir
pour remplacer ce vieux gouvernement qui
me coûte plus cher et que vous apporte
moins avec un nouveau gouvernement qui
vous place en premier pierre poilievre
obtient 68 % des appuis une victoire au
premier tour un résultat sans équivoque
c'est un nombre magique c'est l'unité
pour nous aucune ambiguïté avec
chauffeur de 8% comme ça
le succès d'une campagne au ton souvent
dure aux déclarations parfois
controversés aujourd'hui le gagnant veut
tourner la page il lance un appel à
l'unité des troupes
les attaques ont été eux de chaque côté
mais on va travailler ensemble qu'on a
avec un objectif commun c'est de
remplacer et former le prochain
gouvernement pour jean charest qui
tentait un retour en politique fédérale
c'est une défaite crève coeur lui qui
mettait à l'avant-plan un programme plus
centriste ceux qui l'ont appuyé affirme
que sa présence n'a pas été vaine il ya
plein d'idées qui ont été mis de l'avant
et donc ces idées là peuvent servir pour
l'éventuel chef et moi je cherche photo
garder à l'esprit qu'une course au
leadership c'est également un
laboratoire d'idées et que les joueurs
ont évolué le nouveau chef peut-il
maintenant rebâtir les ponts entre les
différentes factions ce sera son
principal défi à court terme ce sera
surtout ceux qui pourraient déterminer
la suite des choses pour certains
députés et la politique il ya d'autres
choses que les politiques aussi donc je
me sens pas les maths acheter leurs
alliés il est bien là le défi de pierre
poilievre convaincre ses députés qu'ils
ont une place dans son parti sans renier
certaines des positions tranchées qui
l'a énoncé durant la course
on risque de s'aliéner ceux qui l'ont
élu et si daniel thibault radio canada
ottawa